what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
man we are treated to a ton of
spider-man no way home leaks this week
and they're about toby mcguire and
andrew garfield like i mentioned
yesterday when we saw a leaked photo of
andrew garfield these are some of the
biggest leaks that we've ever seen for
the movie and i have news about that
photo it is not fake it's 100 real i'll
go into detail in just a bit but we also
have seen a leaked video of that same
scene plus more and it has audio and i
actually tried a little bit of an
experiment to test if it was all real
and it's kind of funny how i actually
determined this and i'll explain it all
in this video so i'll talk about the
leaked photos the leaked video and the
ways that we know it's real now things
have been getting really intense lately
a lot of leaks coming out so if you love
spider-man and you want to stay up to
date on spider-man no way home and other
marvel mcu movies and tv shows consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of my latest videos so let's
first start off by talking about the
legitimacy of these leaked photos and
videos i've seen some other youtubers
post to their instagrams and twitters
them trying to upload some photos and
them getting blocked the second they
upload the video it says that the video
has been blocked by the owner as a
copyright claim and the video is blocked
worldwide sometimes when you upload a
video to youtube it says it's blocked in
some countries or regents or sometimes
it just says hey you can post it but you
can't make any money off of it because
it's copyrighted material but this is
pretty much as high as it gets it's you
can't show it at all we're not gonna let
you show part of it anything like that
nope you can't show it so this is what i
saw other people talking about so i
tested it myself and yeah it's true i
can't get the photo up and which as i've
been saying before if it's not real it
wouldn't be getting copyrighted i use
fan posters of toby maguire andrew
garfield tom holland all together all
looking very real all the time in my
videos but they don't ever get copyright
claimed because they're not real so it's
a huge sign that these are legitimate
when the studio blocks them from going
up now there are even more signs that
these are real but let's talk about this
leaked video going around and i think
most of you know this especially if you
consider what i just said but i can't
post the video on here unfortunately but
girls and guys if you have twitter if
you have instagram you can find these
i'm not even plugging my own instagram
or twitter right now you can simply go
on them type in spider-man knowing home
in the search bar and they'll probably
come up but let me explain what exactly
is happening here so the leaked photos
that we've been getting of toby maguire
andrew garfield and now tom holland in
the same scene are real but now we have
a video to back that up and this video
actually has audio now it's hard to make
out but i think we understand what
andrew garfield and toby maguire are
saying in this video and it lines up
with well everything so here's what we
see it's a bts video and no not the
k-pop group who i do love but a
behind-the-scenes video of basically
filming but it's a little chaotic and
it's a little chopped up because you can
tell this person obviously is not
supposed to be filming and they are so
they're trying to get away with it so
what we see first is of the film crew we
see a bunch of people kind of together
cameras are out lights are out but most
importantly the background is entirely
blue they have the blue screens up all
around it's a big set it shows us tom
holland spider-man and it actually shows
us footage of the very first photo that
we got for spider-man noway home where
tom holland released the photo of him as
spider-man with a blue background and
him wearing the mask over his face over
his spiderman costume now in this video
he's not wearing the mask he actually
has his mask off and that matches the
other spider-man as well they all have
their masks off and they're all talking
to each other which is why they have
taken them off based off of what we've
seen from these leaked photos in this
video they are in some type of
scaffolding which means they are most
likely pretty high up in the air most
likely on top of the building where
nobody can see them so it's pretty safe
to take their mass off it then cuts to
the famous leaked photo of andrew
garfield he's squatted in the spider-man
position one hand on a rail the other
hand to his side and to the left of the
frame we can actually see a hand the
hand is moving as this person is talking
to andrew garfield spider-man in which
andrew garfield replies now two big
things here one the spider-man on the
left the hand moving on the left is toby
maguire spider-man there is an hd
version of this leaked video out now and
you can very clearly tell that the
spider-man's hand has the raised webbing
design on it which confirms that this is
indeed toby maguire spider-man now we
have seen another leaked photo of this
exact scene before but from a different
angle and that different angle shows
toby maguire spider-man looking up with
andrew garfield spider-man in the same
position on his side so that's another
big verification that this is indeed
toby next to him the two of them are
talking together and tom holland is most
likely in the background somewhere
speaking to them as well now the second
big thing i wanted to mention is i have
now seen the hd version of this and i've
seen it super zoomed in on andrew
garfield yesterday a little mini version
of andrew garfield talking came out and
a lot of people were saying oh it's a
deep fake only his face is moving
nothing else but i made the argument
that it was the greatest deep fake of
all time if it was indeed a deep fake
but in the hd version of this video you
can actually zoom in and you can see
andrew garfield's stomach is moving as
he talks as he breathes his arms are
actually moving his shoulders are
actually moving it's not fake i 100
believe this to be real and i've
actually shown it to a few people who
have said the same thing they thought it
was fake before but now they're like oh
yeah nope that's real now like i said
this person taking this video obviously
was not supposed to be taking this video
so there is a lot of noise a lot of
background noise it's most likely
rubbing up against like a coat or
whatever he is wearing because he's
trying to be incognito about it not get
caught but we still do get some audio
that matches up with what they're saying
now originally i actually thought that
toby maguire said something about banner
as in bruce banner professor hulk and
that could definitely be a possibility
but what i actually think they're
talking about is much better based off
of trying to read andrew garfield's lips
and slowing it down just a little bit
also keep in mind he's talking to toby
maguire spider-man it looks like he's
sane so you have like web blood because
toby mcguire's spider-man doesn't have
web shooters it comes out of him he
produces the web and knowing this so you
have like web blood if you look at that
video for those of you that have seen it
and have kept it it really looks like
that is indeed what he's saying in fact
i'm gonna go ahead and say that's what
he's saying so this is most likely that
scene that we were hoping we would get a
scene where tom holland and andrew
garfield spider-man talk to toby about
how there's the fact that they have web
shooters but toby maguire spider-man
produces them naturally i'm so glad that
we are going to get this scene and it's
kind of just like the difference between
variants like we learned with loki some
of them have very subtle differences but
some of them have kind of a completely
different powers and these are still
very subtle but i'm glad we're getting
this scene because i really wanted them
to talk about this fact and the great
part is is that at this point it's
pretty much confirmed these photos are
real and again i tried to upload a photo
and it got blocked and these photos and
videos aren't even being posted to
reddit right now because they're getting
taken down and they are getting taken
down from twitter and instagram however
it's kind of slow on that part so again
guys if you're trying to see these it's
not hard they're on instagram they're on
twitter i advise against posting them
because you'll get in trouble and the
studio does not want these out but if
you search for them you'll probably find
them regardless let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below and let me know which spider-man
you are most excited to see in
spider-man no way home don't forget to
like the video and of course for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you